[Música]
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en 24 Muchas
gracias
Nos encontramos en la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Bogotá en
Colombia porque ustedes la comisaria de
la exposición que muestra 50 años de
cómics en África para empezar Qué
significa
significa creación imaginaria en suajili
el suajili es una lengua que se habla en
muchos países desde la costa Oriental
hasta África Central y para
micocomisario y para mí fue interesante
encontrar un nombre que despertara
curiosidad que suscitara preguntas Por
qué la k Por qué la u Y por qué no se
dice la francesa sino la u cubuni Y es
que queríamos invitar al público a
pronunciarle bandú que se dice u pero en
Colombia no funciona porque todo el
mundo dice Uh naturalmente de hecho
somos una gran familia neocolombista
Al menos todos pronuncian bien el nombre
el resto del título de la exposiciones
cómics de áfricas con una s Pero
entonces existen en general la expresión
cómica africano en singular existe una
singularidad entre los autores una base
común vínculos evidentes
Así que ese era un segundo reto
conseguir que el visitante se dijera
espontáneamente Ah voy a ver cómics
africanos eso es una cosa que dice todo
el mundo pero teníamos que conseguir Que
salieran de la exposición diciéndose Ah
no sabía que en Nigeria se hacían cómics
así no sabía que aquí se hablara español
Ah Pero espera no sabía que en Kenia se
hicieran cómics Así que ahí lo tienes
llegas con una idea general
relativamente incompleta Porque mucha
gente no sabe que hay cómics en el
África subsahariana y salimos con
identidades nacionales o identidades de
líneas sentiremos las influencias pero
incluso con influencias americanas
europeas o más recientemente asiáticas y
aquí estoy generalizando estoy
exagerando porque todavía no tenemos la
influencia de meoming en los cómics de
África subsahariana y cuando digo
europeas me refiero por supuesto Franco
belgas Pero estas influencias son
absorbidas por la mayoría de los autores
con identidad propia
identidad
por eso era importante la introducción
de la exposición hacer comprender al
visitante que no existe un cómic
africano no existe necesariamente una
África Porque existe el norte de África
e incluso en África subsahariana senegal
y tanzania no hablan la misma lengua no
se comportan de la misma manera Cameron
y Chad que son fronterizos tampoco
comparten la misma lengua Así que ese es
el sentido de la introducción a la
exposición tener esa pequeña precisión
sobre la s de África dura exposición
y crees que África puede sufrir el mismo
camino que América Latina de representar
por ignorancia una misma cultura en la
mente de ciertas personas mientras nunca
se nos ocurriría hablar de cómic europeo
por ejemplo
exactamente creo realmente que estamos
pasando por cosas similares puedo
decirlo porque incluso para Los Cómicos
asiáticos ya sabes que digo asiático
Pero entonces los cómics chinos no se
parecen a los vietnamitas no se parecen
a los coreanos no se parecen a Los
japoneses incluso cuando en la
superficie se puede decir que se parecen
en cuanto te metes en los libros ves
claramente que no es lo mismo en
absoluto y en Europa no decimos cómics
europeos decimos cómics alemanes o
portugueses o españoles o cómics Franco
belgas o cómics suizos
Así que ahí lo tienen creo que con
América Latina realmente compartimos
este tipo de cliché como en el
hemisferio sur porque no somos muy
conocidos Todavía no Estamos
suficientemente representados en el
panorama mundial del cómic Y ese es el
sentido de tener una exposición
patrimonial como cubuni para entablar
conversaciones y crear puentes con los
países a los que viaja la exposición
hablar de África en plural entendimos
que era el objetivo central de esta
exposición y en términos de números es
todo un éxito 50 artistas de 48 países
diferentes es colosal cómo fue el
trabajo de búsqueda y de selección
Sí sí le quisieron
Esa es la cuestión que menos me gusta
explorar porque sigue siendo muy difícil
de hecho como resumir 48 países de un
continente en una exposición digerible
comprensible y fácil de representar para
un público que pasa por allí Así que fue
realmente un gran reto para Jean
micomisario que es asesor científico en
la ciudad Internacional del cómic y de
la imagen de angulem y para mí además
trabajamos en esta exposición en un
periodo maravilloso porque ahora hay un
mundo antes del covid y un mundo después
del covid estábamos A mediados del año
cero cuando trabajamos en esta
exposición Así que no fue fácil ni obvio
Pero al final es lo no fácil y no obvio
lo que hace que la experiencia sea
interesante y galvanizadora
ya conocíamos a bastantes autores hay
que saber que en 2013 algunos
historiadores del cómic en el continente
es decir incluyendo el magreb habían
enumerado más de 1.300 autores en activo
pero que evidentemente no son conocidos
fuera del continente y a veces ni
siquiera conocidos fuera de su país de
residencia
Así que como dijimos en lugar de
lanzarnos a una loca carrera de
identidades desde el principio vamos a
hacer una exposición patrimonial que
recorra la historia del cómic
subsahariano de la imagen narrativa ya
que hay historia en imágenes hay una
fuerte cultura pictórica en el
Continente Así que vamos a hacer una
transición entre la imagen narrativa y
el arte secuencial y esto nos llevó a
fragmentar la exposición de manera
temporal en lugar de agrupar las obras
por países o de otra manera
Por eso tiene una parte introductoria
que establece el contexto del continente
africano y de África como acabamos de
hacer y luego hablamos del pasado de Los
Pioneros de los que hicieron el
despertar y la edad de oro y por último
de la joven generación del cómic
subsahariano que utiliza las redes
sociales
exactamente que es totalmente
desinhibido que explora todo tipo de
temas incluso temas tabú temas que son
muy difíciles de abordar en el cómic Así
que esa fue nuestra metodología
quería terminar nuestra entrevista con
el hecho de que eres Cuco comisaría de
esta exposición pero también creaste el
festival y sobre todo eres ilustradora y
autora de cómics estas múltiples
funciones que te hacen viajar y conocer
gente alimentando inspiración como
artista
lea me gusta como lo has presentado
porque es como una muñeca rusa iba
realmente de lo más grande algo más
pequeño en el fondo soy guionista de
cómics y viajar me enriquece por
supuesto y cuando eres guionista de
cómics transmites un mensaje escribes
para un público y el mensaje que
transmitimos es lo que hará que a la
gente que le gusta Lucky Loop por
ejemplo aunque sea un hombre blanco que
viaja por el lejano oeste de Estados
Unidos y habla todas las lenguas del
mundo porque cuando abro mi cómic en
francés me habla en francés pero en el
fondo no sabe hablar francés
Es que escribes para un público sea cual
sea su color de piel escribes para un
público sea cual sea su experiencia
transmites algo universal y por eso como
persona que escribe cómics para mí es
muy rico y estimulante estar aquí y
conocer a las comunidades de diferentes
raíces colombianas
también soy directora de un festival de
cómic cree uno que este va a cumplir 8
años el festival de bilir y vedéz que es
de hecho un festival plataforma que nos
permite conectar el mayor número posible
de perfiles que carecen de visibilidad
Así que como autora de cómics he hecho
una serie que se llama la vida de
benjutta soy una residente pura del
continente africano cada vez tengo
problemas con los visados para salir y
todo eso así que decidí crear un
festival para facilitar la conexión
entre perfiles pequeños medianos y muy
grandes para contrarrestar la realidades
para cambiar las cosas y el camino de
los jóvenes artistas Exacto
exactamente y para escribir de una
manera nueva el resultado y las
consecuencias de decisiones que se han
tomado y que escapan totalmente a
nuestro control Así que son todos estos
sombreros los que conforman mi identidad
y es un bagaje que llevo por supuesto
pero me siento aún más honrada cuando
hablo de mi trabajo como autora de poder
valorar a otros autores y después de un
encuentro digas Ah sí conocimos a Joel
también descubrimos con ella gente como
diría casay de la República
centroafricana guanican Ah no sabíamos
que había mujeres que hacían cómics
afrofantasía Ah pero que está cebra
cómics que también hace cómics en
español y alemán sin embargo están en
Camerún en la zona anglófona Así que ahí
lo tienes Me gusta esta multi identidad
que me permite no solo hablar de mi
trabajo sino también presentar un poco
de escaparate de lo que está sucediendo
en el continente y en particular en el
África subsahariana
Joel Muchas gracias Sí muchas gracias y
gracias a ustedes por su confianza sigan
con nosotros hay más cultura en 24 y
tras 24.com
[Música]